sure i'm eric rudersgold
with johnson tractor been with johnson
tractor for 19 years
started our precision farming department
and have grown it to now two and a half
people we've got two full-time guys and
one intern
that do our precision farming and with
me today is adam hinkle our precision
farming specialist at rochelle
been kind of a separate department for
about three years now
it's where we've taken it from being
somebody that can handle it part-time to
needing a full-time person and now at
least two full-time people it's a
separate whole separate division or a
whole separate department
um but eventually to become more
mainstream as it comes new on the
equipment
you know technicians are involved more
and more just like an option on a
tractor was a couple years ago now it's
part of the equipment so they'll be
involved in
setting it up fixing it just like they
would another piece of the tractor so
um more or less getting up to date with
the new equipment how to operate it run
it how everything ties together i mean
the monitors now
they can control the charger themselves
so it's a matter of knowing how each
monitor works with the various pieces of
equipment how we can tie that together
and make it work for the farmer
we've got some customers that grow some
specialty crops some seed corn
and with the price of seed corn for that
specialty stuff being expensive as it is
they want some
shutoff control so they're not
overlapping wasting seed and inputs
so we've got
several customers that do that kind of
stuff that we've helped them out
that kind of stuff
yeah i mean that does go along well with
growing seed corn you need to build that
row shutoffs where you're maybe you're
not planting a bull row
with the new technologies it makes it a
lot simpler go out there fill your
hoppers and just go plant not have to be
getting out all the time turn rows on
and off it's not simple